who's gonna see that i was watching that
oj [ __ ] yeah you don't know the oj story
so he started watching us oh yeah i
obviously i know the [ __ ] surface
level [ __ ] i got
i got my master degree yeah you got your
mask he's got his masters in oj
i'll go through the whole thing yeah
yeah guys
i saw that because yeah they completely
changed that uh house
oh yeah you talking about where she was
murdered yeah yeah that town house
yeah i drove by it you drove by on this
anniversary i drove by it
oh who's the address has changed nicole
kidman yeah they changed the address
the residence is different they knocked
it all down because they
because they don't want dumbasses to
drive by all the time well because
that's what was happening i guess
yeah i guess that's what like it was
just such a [ __ ]
torso it's weird when you go those
murder sites like i went to
charles manson where they murdered
champagne can't wait what's the point
well because i like because i read so i
don't know why i read so much about
it i want to visually see like the
historic
darkness that went down so like when i
drove to sharon tate's house
it's creepy man because i know okay
because i i study it so much
i know exactly where tex walks in parked
the car i know the walk they made
so you can read about it when you like
when you're there like you can park
where he parked
when you're there and you're like what
that it's just weird yeah i know i can
like put it all together
and you can see they all right they
parked here at the end of the hill they
walked up hill
here murdered sharon tate and the folger
and the rest of her it's nuts
you feel like a pi i know right yeah you
you're super dude
i get scared like it it's creepy as [ __ ]
man it is really really creepy
all that shit's creeping in i i don't
know well that book got ringing on the
plane
the the night stalker book it's like the
the balls deep in the night stalker they
get into like
the murders and hit him in prison and
all this stuff
what was weird with that nightstalker
stuff the murders are so intense and so
scary
i wouldn't read it on my own like i get
scared sometimes it's so graphic i put
the book down
i'm like [ __ ] why do i read this stuff i
put it down and then like an hour go by
on the fly i'm like let me see this [ __ ]
i only have like 50 pages left but it's
scary man
you were reading coming from cleveland
yeah that's starting cleveland i'm
almost done with it now spoken because i
only read on i can't read at home my
kids like get the [ __ ] out of here
so i only read on planes but then uh
what's weird about him is like
gets busted clearly he's the murderer
there's evidence all over from a shoe
print to his dna
huge because he'd rape him so his
evidence is all over the place
and his family was like there's no way
he did this so his family come visit him
and he's like they're framing me they're
framing this is ridiculous i didn't do
this
just trying to put on a poor mexican kid
his family's like yeah that's right
like what the [ __ ] like look just look
at all and then
he would murder people and ask for you
know jewelry and cash before he murdered
him
then he would take that jewelry wedding
rings bracelets necklaces that are
specific to that person i murdered
and send to a sister so they went to a
sister's house and like has
has the night starter giving you any
jewelry and she was like
yeah and they're like let us see so they
open up it's all the people that's been
murdered jewelry
she's like i don't believe he did it
it's like are you out of your [ __ ]
mind
that'll be like they're just show by the
oblivious because it's their brother
he was like the little brother and
they're like there's no way he did it
and then even when he was in prison
he was like i'm just gonna say guilty
and they're like no you gotta fight this
because you're innocent
and you could tell he was like yeah
they're just gonna frame me so i'm
[ __ ] either way
he's like i'm say guilty because
obviously he's guilty yeah
and then he had so many hoes coming
after him so many hosts like
they said the wardens like the security
of the prison were like we've never seen
anything like this
so many girls wanted to [ __ ] him they
thought it was so like he was so
handsome no conjure no visits he could
talk to him on the phone
and like he got he had like die hard
like ride or die [ __ ]
so weird right it's weird that you read
it
yeah i don't know why well when cat was
at the house
when cows at house the new book team
says why are people so in love with
serial killers
cause i'm trying to figure out that's a
there's a book about that yeah i got
them yeah brendan
just got it why is there other people
out there that's infatuated with serial
killer well
i hear you i hear you but driving up to
people
this is absolutely this is i know i'm
saying you wanted to go to that [ __ ]
hotel
again you talking about him but again
here's what's interesting
i'd see jay was like hey a lot of people
emailed firing the kid
shop at gmail.com a lot of people you
the hotels you can't
get yeah yeah you can't go there i was
not able to book anything so i don't
know what's happening you said
yeah people were dming me and saying
yeah you
that would be able to tell off maine now
stay on main or something like that yeah
i'll stay on main there yeah man they
changed the name
it'd been fun to do it but man it's just
when you look more into it dude
you want to talk about a terrible
[ __ ] person yeah i mean yeah
what about that girl at the uh water
tower uh
that's mental health yeah shout out to
mental health betterhelp.com promo code
shop
that's all that she's just way to put
she was on she was on the meds well
that's the thing that kind of like
you know looking at that story it's like
people want to say she was like
demonized
and stuff like that it's like crazy man
like and meanwhile her folks
yeah are sitting here saying no she
really looks like the conspiracy is way
more fun to say yep because what
actually happened is she was on
medication
didn't take her meds she had these crazy
episodic
things happen before where they find her
under beds terrified things somebody's
chasing her
she decides to take a truck and you know
journey
down to california goes to all these
spots yeah stop taking her medication
she just happens to be at that creepy
hotel didn't take her meds
wanders off climbs in the water tower
they didn't think they'd look in the
[ __ ] water tower they found her crazy
ass and they're dead
they saw yeah mental illness man look
how boring
there was someone that uh broke it down
they were like it's so easy to get into
that water tower
yeah they they literally had their
phones
they're getting sued for it because it
shouldn't be that easy yeah and then
they're like well why was the top
closed when they found her how would a
person drown to close the top
and then the the janitor was like well i
was checking the lifetime i opened it
saw she's in there freaked out and
closed it oh
yeah he was like case solved like i
closed it yeah
people like no you did it i know yeah
she's demonized yeah and i'm like man
that's mental health man
yeah i mean like it's crazy yeah all
right brendan
people really believe in that stuff
though it's so fun dude
wrong i love it it's so fun uh-huh but
it's yeah
but the charles manson one's even weird
the charles benson ones to me
the most strange case there is because
he was doing
he was an experiment with the cia with
lsd and
in ashburton he had
he was out on parole he would violate
his pro all the time
and people like hey man charles manson's
right there like he violated all these
pearls go arrest him
and every cop in that county like no
like we're it's higher up than this
we're not allowed to [ __ ] with them
you're like why wouldn't they [ __ ] why
why can't they [ __ ] with them it's just
that charles manson's [ __ ] a weird
case dude
fury chaos by uh i forget the author
it's it
brenda you think i'm gonna read these
books it'd be good i didn't even want to
go to that damn hotel
yeah i'm definitely not i didn't even
after i read what uh
because you know when you watch the
documentary on night stalker
it kind of gives you just how bad he is
there it is that
that's the best serial killer book in
the world thomas the best serial killer
book
it's the most important book the whole
sentence it's the most interesting book
you will ever read
ever as far as charles manton's free
review the best book of all time
it's it's it's i couldn't put it down
it's [ __ ] captivating
so the cia had their hands on charles
yes and the
regular police couldn't touch him yep
well it did get a 408 out of five
his parole officer in san francisco like
helped him out
and they let it just it doesn't make
sense it doesn't make it all of it
doesn't make sense
and then i'll like the whole narrative
that that the real famous book came
out that uh not pelosi jesus christ
i forget the guy who wrote it oh uh
helter skelter
helped his counselor i heard it man
helter skelter
was the book that the prosecutor uh
vince vincent uh booga boogaliosi
bugaloosi
he wrote it and this was also his
defense saying that
you know he started a race war and you
know he was into the beatles and he did
it to create all this race stuff
and then charles manson's like i don't
like the beatles he's like that's a
beach boys guy
see i don't listen to [ __ ] beatles he
was like that makes sense dude
so like he painted this whole narrative
that he's crazy and he
launched this race warning he's like
what he's like
so why do you put the swastika on his
head just to look crazy because he
there's a point when he was on trial
he's like oh i'm never getting up so i'm
just gonna lean into the crazy [ __ ]
but they also try to make him look crazy
because he you
may have you see him in those those
videos is really long here in the beard
he's like i asked oh yeah my haircut and
shave
so i looked like a [ __ ] normal person
but they went they wouldn't let me
because they knew i looked [ __ ] crazy
brittany you balls deep in this [ __ ]
what else do you like well hello
before you ask that question before you
ask that question what what are your
other interests
this might be a weird question but let
me ask you brendon
well who's the best serial killer in
your mind because i asked why i know
it's a weird question
because it's the balls the btk killer
was
[ __ ] pretty gruesome he he didn't get
caught forever but the number the best
as far as if you're going to say best
like most deaths
was this guy who worked in an old folks
home in hospital
because you know old people they die but
he would be like oh cool and then just
like someone's grandma cover their nose
and mouth
kill him be like oh man she passed away
this is so sad and then he came out and
was like
they finally killed like 80 people like
[ __ ] you killed my grandma
like she was going anyway yeah he's like
the most
as far as successfully
he was so hard to track can't they tell
that though
no so i don't tell bro you can't like
oh no no no no because they were they're
on ventilators like breathing meant
because they had
issues breathing already yeah so he just
unhook it this
this this the [ __ ] yeah 50 patients
yeah you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] coward coward
yo i can't be so here go to different
nursing homes take their
man my grandmother
250 people well they couldn't think
about they couldn't figure out your
grandma goes there and she's like on her
last leg
and like yeah stay less and then just
[ __ ] kill him well he looked like he
was on his last leg and look at this
then no one checked into it because
they're just old people so he got away
with it
forever this was in the uk who was
keeping count
he was he'll just kill an old person
tally it up uh
bound torture kill guy was creepy as
[ __ ] tortured cool yeah btk killer he
looked normal he had like a family was
he was he
executed that way
man that's that guy from always sunny
and in philadelphia
don't you dare compare him to danny
devito
how dare you he he i need the veto is a
gift
he was awful he was what now what was
his deal bound torture kill so he would
he would uh tie the people up and then
while he's raping
oh yeah that's that's one of his victims
he put mask on him and [ __ ] he'd wear
weird [ __ ]
but he was married and so he would like
he would kill
and then his wife suspected so he went
on a break was he was
like five years later bad bad dude
piece of [ __ ] wow yeah yeah that is
weird is it was he a cop b
because he was that him down there on
the right no uh sorry
right there in the middle is that him
right there no
that look like him maybe it's not him
or maybe that's the person that caught
up not that
that is him that is him was he a cop
what is his yeah what is his outfit
fine torture kill 10 people wichita
kansas
and wha what around this was in the
90s no he said it has to be 80s they
said the 80s at the bottom
oh is that guy dead
hopefully real piece of [ __ ] tennis
damn i never heard of these uh killers
at all yeah right
creepy stuff well what's weird is the
narrative that uh
ted bundy's like this handsome serial
killer it's like
ted bundy was smart like he he is he
handsome
i don't not not compared to i know this
is weird to say but not compared to
uh ramirez maybe let me be the judge
do you think he was handsome for the
time and like where he was killing like
those areas like he was good looking
like you know how there's like a la and
then like uh he's a cleveland
he's like a cleveland seven he did it in
cleveland he did oh he did it cleveland
utah oh he went he went uh got it he
went places but he was handsome so charm
girls in the house
i don't know what this guy looks like
can you show me yeah
[ __ ] you good chin yeah chin dropped his
cradle
yeah sniff it sniff it you won't um
it's a wrap i don't think ted is that
handsome but
he's not like zac efron played him in
the movie on netflix
zac efron's a dime piece yeah oh yes
he's
he's compared to richard ramirez i think
it's his jawline or something
richard ramirez those blue eyes
you're right dude but richard remembers
that long hair crime
richard ramirez oh man no a compared oh
come on dude oh hold on
though it's the hair yeah yeah
he's a good looking dude he looked like
the guy from american horse
wait who's that girl he's oh is that
actually he uh added him in as a
character
yeah he was in the 1970s one what yeah
1989 right
that was like the first american no that
was the one that was the last one the
last one just kidding
was on that one just kidding but as far
as like if we're talking about
good-looking serial killers he's numero
who knows son
yeah that's the thing that's the thing
some of the girls that he raped they
didn't kill
they weren't describing them he was a
very good-looking
latino guy
wait when did you get his teeth fixed
while he was in prison so they thought
he was hot with bad teeth
but they said he was very attractive to
open his mouth and that's when
that's one of the ways he got caught he
had like all these cavities and his
teeth were all [ __ ] up and
he went to a dentist in uh koreatown and
he's supposed to come back
so they had cops wait in there and
pretend they were waiting
but he never came like he was previewed
to it he was hot to it so never came
back
but there oh yeah they're like he's
gonna have to figure out his teeth
because he's in so much pain yeah
he's good looking and you know what he
you know what he was a big uh rock fan
so
before murders he'd listen to ac dc
highway to hell
and he had a dope ac dc hat and then he
killed one person his hat fell off
brendan yeah you're an encyclopedia for
this yeah what book
is like people infatuated with serial
killers yeah yeah how deep are you into
that
i've even started yeah i'm trying to
figure out this one it is it is
interesting
you're not the only person like no
people like like these [ __ ]
murder mystery docs on [ __ ] netflix
are like
so [ __ ] popular meanwhile i have no
interest the number one podcast
ain't rogan ain't [ __ ] fighting the
kid ain't king of sting ain't bad
friends not crystalia
it's it's uh crime murder mystery really
it's like serial
the apology line like that stuff the
biggest like demo dude
because you have all like housewives and
[ __ ] listening to it not just 18 to 36
bros
like there's so many more like just but
i thought i thought it was a lot of
females that like to listen to that they
do like my mom
i don't know why i am interested in my
my mama's
have you always been into i've been in
it because my mom was into it so she
would watch dateline and [ __ ] well when
i was like a kid i'd watch my mom let me
watch like freddy krueger
and like good fella like yeah killing it
yes
but again like you meet people like
brendan or my mom you would never
suspect that they're any kind of my mom
watched snap religiously i'm like girl
these are all episodes
like snap is like women who like snap
her husband
her husband all right i was like why you
keep watching this feels like a
beginning is it uh is it a scripted
series
no it's not scripted it's like real talk
oh it's it's yeah
what yeah
is it like that is it like it's a white
halo movie enough enough nothing but she
she beat him up
that [ __ ] was so unrealistic
[Applause]
oh you want to go and then my favorite
buddy is like you want to go
she's awful she tried to do ls she's all
wow hey some people can learn a lot
about it
she had a right hand i wish that she was
realistic she'd been like oh
have you all seen enough with jlo are
you serious
i haven't how about that when i get off
stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son